[Music]
I'm starting the show by powdered my
face was I was just old I'm feeling for
me that I'm shocked
I like the circuits show the question Oh
God can we start with up that met met
one last time we did a bad back
can I get a bet that met me okay what's
your question I just wanna show the
question cried Monte why are you like
this yeah I just want to know I think
you should know by now why I'm like this
Benton it's called a bad childhood next
question was it the only one have asked
this show everyone I would just let I'm
literally powdering my nose like a
damsel in distress in like a 30s movie
do I look okay
you can't run in place that I look like
I'm covered in KY jelly today because I
really lubed up the more anxious I am
the more oil i slather on my face we do
not have a guest on the show today it's
been a very hectic last month for a
litany of reasons evolving cancel cancel
I don't have any friends left no I I
think it's very important that when I do
this show I practice what I preach on
the show and a big thing we talk about
on the show is knowing when your glass
is not full and when you have nothing to
give when you are not able to show up as
your best self and being able to say
uncle when you need a break and knowing
when you're gonna show up as your best
self and I am emotionally depleted to
say the least and I think having a guest
on today would have been I would not
have been able to show up because your
glass is only half full my glass is only
half full gotta fill it up any more mail
it's full of Hemlock so it's a tricky
it's been a tricky last couple weeks I'm
sure you guys know why but I'm just um
we're gonna do a catch-up episode with
Benton who we haven't seen in a while
two episodes haven't seen you in two
episodes and I want to talk about some
things today that I just want to get off
my chest
that are you know don't have to the
headlines are so bleak right now
everything is so apocalyptic we're just
gonna talk about some silly shit like
our fight silly you want to do this
yesterday Benton had the gall the
audacity to come in on a Saturday
morning just smoke coming out of his
ears would you like to tell as a young
millennial entrepreneur do you want to
explain people why you start a fight
with me yesterday I didn't start a fight
with you I came in with a great business
ideas I was like hey you want to make
money you like making money and then I
gave you these wonderful ideas Benton's
stormed in and was like you're leaving
money on the table
I didn't say that I make bobblehead
dolls there's not figures I was it's
10:00 a.m. can I just finish my coffee
and then we'll talk about the bobblehead
business like what are you talking about
he's like thing you weren't even put I'm
like I already had a robot made of
myself now a bobblehead dolls what it
what are you what are we saying yes I
was like you need pins button the pot
figures oh my god he started going crazy
with me about how much money I'm leaving
on the table and how many clicks Jessica
Alba gets on using it's true I was
pulling up receipts and I thought I was
making great points I thought everybody
agreed with me but you what you are
I just what's the what is you I just
want you to feel seen and heard what
what listen I thought I was coming in as
a great friend with helpful I thought
she's gonna be on the phone with like
agents and managers like you have things
to do but instead it turned out that I
need to do them so who knew it was I
think I think what happened was Benton
came in with all these like business
proposals for me and all these things
that I need to do to like add a
PowerPoint presentation set up and I
think this is the week of my entire life
in the public eye that I've wanted to be
less known I think one week where I
didn't want to be more successful be or
I want it to be less of a public figure
and you just came in and we're like
let's put you in Toys R Us yeah I think
they're close I think cancelled by the
way I misspelled every word with an R
for at least ten years because of Toys R
Us I
think best during trauma I'm a surgeon
so that's why I had a lot of ideas
god I gotta got it so you came in and
what I heard was you need to be more
famous and for me
it's really I don't and I don't like I
don't I feel like I'm the perfect amount
of famous I was like I was like record a
pop album quick like I mean it was well
but what how like the fact that this
last week being a public figure meant I
had to do something like incredibly
scary and it was like the first week I
was like I would like to be less of a
public figure it would be nice just like
grieve about a horrible thing and not
have to like draft a statement for four
days and then get death threats wouldn't
that be nice and yeah so it was like the
one I think week that I was like not
feeling particularly ambitious about my
business I was like I would actually
just like to move to Albuquerque and
work at a toe ring kiosk we'll see what
I thought was you get knocked down nine
times you get up ten did you get off of
a Snapple Bacardi B lyric
it's a cardi B lyric and I meant it but
do you worry that I'm not successful
enough for some no I don't worry about
that at all I think you have cleared
queer dysmorphia and so I just want to
tune you back into option what does that
mean it's like I sometimes I think did
you forget all the things you can do
because you're just focused on the way
that TV was or the way that comedy was
when things were so you do those things
that you're super good at and I'm just
like you know there's something easier
things you could do for some big chunks
of money
Benton wants me to be a YouTube star no
I just want to add it in I just want to
add it in Ben Tennyson wants me so badly
to be a YouTube star and I'm like are
you as YouTube fame going so well for
these people I did not want you to be a
YouTube star like I said do we have a
channel you have a channel so you could
do more with it here's my deal with all
this I like to wait I like to be the
last person in the fucking burning
building okay that's my whole thing with
podcasts I was like Mara know comics
sitting around talking to each other for
five hours a week that doesn't feel like
it's gonna end well let me just like
feel this out YouTube stars filming
yourself for 10 straight years like that
I'm sure this is gonna the
she was gonna drop at some point I guess
you just figure there's like a couple
vacancy a vacant spot let's get you in
late night yeah just watches all the
cancellations like there's a slot cuz in
order for a woman to be successful nine
guys have to do blackface be the last
one left gonna be the last person
standing there like well might as well
like for a funny girl to be as
successful as a funny guy he has to be
half as funny but just have done
blackface before yes there's a lot of
stuff coming guys get ready we have a
lot of projects for working on we can't
talk about them right now people have to
say that we can't talk about our
projects right now but we do have some
on the way what is a way to be a bobble
head doll pop vinyls first of all what's
a pop - do you ever know that it is in
this room yes though they're these a
little tiny like cute figurines of like
things like there's one I got food
there's ones like The Devil Wears Prada
there's one for like all these TV shows
movies characters I think ed Sheeran has
one like they're just people and they're
excited they're like $7 but then they
only last for so long and when you try
to rebuy it like I have some that
already only last like they're on
they're limited so I have something but
when you look them up now to buy like
200-300 dollars okay so I'm just
thinking like two Broke Girls will be
cool pop vinyls like you would be a cool
pop vinyl that's probably so they're
like the new beanie babies yeah but you
want me to be a total cool yeah okay I
need to be a toy I appreciate how much
you believe in me I mean all you can do
is like super fucking shiny like a super
shiny to make super shiny shiny fucking
glitter face doll I just I mean I don't
know who you pitched that idea to but
I'm thinking you could just pitch like
hey here's something I bet there's some
female I love to do this - I just like
to ask that question she's like nobody
I'm like well there's be somebody we can
tell like and trust me I don't know I
like everything everything works
butthole coming up like you should be on
that billboard on sunset should we go
down I really do like I think you have
to ask someone there's a golden Ross
that's bent it's like I got my
paintbrush let's go paint you on the
side of this I'm like man I did that
with the walking
the Taylor Swift album came out and I
was like you should direct a music video
for her yeah I have nowhere but the
person that knows firsthand more than
anyone how busy I am is like and you
should also direct Taylor Swift's music
videos and like with what time I just
found it fun to me speaking of stuff on
my plate we're touring Tori we are
touring and you know that I have to
basically rewrite a whole new hour to go
on tour with because every joke I was
doing before the pandemic now makes
absolutely no sense now that there's an
invisible murderer in the air like I was
doing jokes about like when you shake
hands with a man as a woman they give
you feedback on how strong your
handshake is like no one shakes hands
anymore like that joke is gone forever
like I have to write a whole new hour of
stand-up because we're going to what San
Diego a historical joke maybe you're a
history comic yes San Diego July 16
through 19
this is our first show back during the
pandemic I hope it doesn't get cancelled
well we'll see
July 30th if they're August first we'll
be in Salt Lake City SLC so those are
the two up comers yeah excuse me okay
that's a word I made Tempe are we gonna
Tempe Anela Alabama we're going to those
two and then we go to to Miami Oklahoma
oh that's right I forgot about that home
of the little casinos okay and then what
that's August 22nd and then Atlanta
Georgia September 24th okay yeah the
rest of the website I now want to talk
about something that's really been
upsetting me and that needs to be
discussed which is that I would like to
just enjoy some of the summer if
possible I'm trying to buy swimsuits and
they're all fucking heinous why can I
not buy a swimsuit that is flattering
the trend in swimsuits now is we're back
to high cut low cut up the thigh granny
panties swimsuits all the swimsuits look
why do I have to look like a boy from
the 30s taking a dip in the Catskills
why can't we have why is fashion now
just going back to shit that was ugly in
the 50s all of this woman's you've seen
them they're just like those fifties
it's just very Oh look like big tight
diapers like they're all like those nap
there's dude they're from an era when
boobs were the most important I don't
need my ass to look flatter than it
already is these high cut swimsuits that
go super low like on your hips they make
your back in your front basically look
the same it's not it makes your butt
look like a little like two little
scallops yeah they were cut for women
who were standing behind stoves you only
saw this high up like that's very much
what it is it's just like a stop-start
trying to put me in these 50s but I'm
not bringing you a drink watching Mad
Men it's not happening yeah is it
because women are getting like more
powerful that we have to like put them
back into outfits from back when they
were less powerful just as some kind of
like stalls yeah like literally why am I
wearing a bikini that women wore when
they couldn't vote like why do I have to
do is this what you need me to do to
make myself smaller compared all these
male designers making those bathing
suits you don't want to live in the 50s
either if you're a fashion designer
every bathing suit when I go shot they
all look like fucking Mary Ann from
Gilligan's Island swimsuits right good
reference thank you I was like ginger
Mary Ann like I didn't really know
there's an it's never flattering like
you why you look like a fucking station
wagon it's literally the equivalent
immediately I got you a swimsuit you're
like that's an apron I'm like I know
it's also I just I don't understand why
fashion you we make progress we figured
out a way to make swimsuits that are
actually flattering and we're like now
now let's go back to the ugliest shit
ones and that's supposed to be
fashionable this is why I call bullshit
on fashion all the time there's no new
ideas or there's no sticking with
something that worked why don't we just
stick with a flattering swimsuit and do
like a new color or like a new pattern
why do we have to go back to this weird
ass lie crouched like they look like
like pregnancy jeans you know those
materials better just like all roused up
like it's just not I why are our only
choices for swimsuits now just like ugly
and hideous I just think we should all
wear
our wetsuits do not that mean wetsuits
and flippers well okay I don't I don't
know what your hobbies are swimming I
also how about how about we got we
figured out cute swimsuits it's been
solved this is a problem that's been
solved let's stick with the progress of
it how about you now put your time and
energy into figuring out men's swimsuits
because ever I've never seen a guy in a
swimsuit who didn't look like he had a
giant erection all the time but there's
a there's a kind of ventilation issue or
like puckering problem where guys always
look like they have a huge hard-on what
do we even call it boner hard-on
erection what do we say chubby we just
talk about it I'm just saying like why
don't you put some time we figured out
female swimsuits go work on the guys
they're there they have not been
mastered yet have we figured out female
swimsuits because they're still putting
belts on them Benten do not do this
unless you're ready they're belting
women if you're gonna put a belt on a
swimsuit it better be a fanny pack
because I need some butter for my Teddy
Grahams I hate an unnecessary accessory
like a fucking button with no hole or
glasses that aren't prescription or like
pockets that are fake like when you're
hanging out with a girlfriend you like
hey can you throw this in your pocket
and she's like they're not real pocket
therefore show their first show pocket
like you had costumes this is just like
so classic like extra this is just what
we do as human beings we can't we can't
just be simple oh and the worst is when
it's a belt in the front but there's no
belt in the back like it's just a half
about for show I think if we're gonna
put belt or somebody a little holsters
on it I just don't I don't like and I
think the thing that bothers me I don't
like going back to retro styles because
it's maybe it's because we're going back
to retro news headlines I don't know
what's going on maybe maybe it's in fact
at every headline that we have now in
the news could have happened in the
fucking early 1900s
it's like pandemic race issues like
women not able to like people not being
able to vote like why why are our
headlines and our clothing now going
back to the early 1900s I mean no answer
but do you know what's worse than a belt
good segue Benton are you gonna really
piss me off
yeah I
don't even get me started this my number
one pet peeve in the summer it's
summertime and I want to tell you what I
would not like to see if I see one
American flag bikini I swear to God
okay it has never sat right with me why
are the most patriotic people wearing an
American flag over their buttholes I
know I know I see you and I know at some
point in the day you have farted on the
American flag and I will not have it it
is wrong I do not believe the American
flag should be wedged into your crevices
while you're playing beer pong
okay there's plenty of cute swimsuits
out there that are not American flag
patterns that you can buy it's like I
mean imagine like Betsy Ross mr. Ross is
hand stitching a thong she did not sign
up for this she's rolling in her grave
like my my grandfather always said my
grandfather fought in the war and he
always he said not only can American
flags not touch the ground he said they
had to be folded a certain way so keep
him out of your folds this summer please
exactly literally I want to respect the
American flag at all times but you're
wearing it as pasties and you're drunk
on jello shots and it's making it really
hard for me not puke on the American
flag plea also this goes for guys
swimsuits - like god there's a lot of
like for like American flag board shorts
young and stuff like that I do not want
the stars and stripes on your Frank and
beans if you're gonna wear a fly just
pick a different flag maybe like a
meeting maybe like a medieval times flag
like you cover up your Lady of the lake
with a good King Arthur flag that's a
lady of the lake is that your that's
what I call the jean Lady of the lake
the King Arthur joke you're really
ruining it okay is the lake from do you
know the lady like is no oh she's a
mythical being oh well cuz cardi B says
make me feel like a lake or something I
don't know cuz you quote a Carla cardi B
the 10 minutes ago listen don't come for
me a lady of the lake that is just
stressed me out I like it I think we
should make mashed be merge
[Laughter]
oh okay the last Admiral I do have some
pot here's the thing the fact that you
and I are giving fashion advice is
shocking oh my god
it's truly it's brilliant that you and I
have any opinions on fashion given the
fact that I exclusively wear shirts with
but from gas stations wolves and horses
on them just wearing our own merch at
all times
here's something I am excited about with
fact Chong which is that I as you guys
can see if you're not listening if your
watch not watching on YouTube I am
wearing a tie-dye I'm wearing today
yeah but not cuz you're trying to look
young because you're trying to sell that
shirt I am so nervous about wearing
tie-dye cuz it's very trendy I don't
want you guys to think that I like think
I'm young or something but I'm just
excited that tie-dye is like so back in
style in a way that is like for cool
people because the when tie-dye came
around in the 90s when I was a teenager
it wasn't cool like it wasn't for cool
kids like it was for weirdos like in the
90s
tie-dye was for like the weirdo like
Grateful Dead guy who like worked at the
video store who like played hacky sack
like it was for hacky sack guys what did
you wear airbrush t-shirts in the mall
kiosk I wore Hootie the Blowfish shirt
with my jellies and my skort thank you
very much okay I grew up tight I was
just for Bible Camp
okay we just wore to Bible Camp they
split us up into color groups and that
was it but what but like I'm excited
that today is now for cool carriage for
the coolest kids because also by the way
back when I had tie-dye in the 90s it
was also physically fucking dangerous
because we had a product called a hyper
color shirt which was a tie-dye shirt
except gave you cancer it was it was it
would based on your body heat it would
tie dye itself in real time just when
you walked around it would be pink and
then you would sweat and then it would
turn like purple and then it would turn
pink it was like a mood which is so
moving for your nipples
Darley and it was definitely chock full
of poisonous chemicals no a hundred
percent and I even back then like I knew
something was off
about it because it was like everyone
had to have a hypercolor shirt and pumps
sneakers to fit in and I remember
wearing a hypo color shirt and you would
just like I said taste like I'm sucking
on a nickel like you would be like
that's a mentally aftertaste or you just
be like why am I is my vision getting
blurry like uh someone dipped a t-shirt
and lead paint and then sold it to you
there's no way that that didn't do
damage to my generation wearing those
chemically as shirts all I still have
like a little like my knee like pops
every now and then - and I'm like how
about my underboob sweat would just be a
constant different color that's exactly
what happened
it would just be horrible your armpits
and your under boobs there'd be like
smiley faces and then it would just you
just walk around do you guys know I'm
gross
I always suck I just wonder I definitely
everyone know I'm fucking gross I stink
I smell and I can't breathe real good I
have asthma but I'm cute as hell so
anyway I'm glad that now tie-dye is
available to people without the whole
like chemicals in your bloodstream side
effect the other thing though that
happens to me in the summer like I'm
like looking for bathing suits like I
was like you know me I don't really go
swimming but I've been trying to like be
fun given the the nightmare that is we
call life this haunted house that we're
all trying to navigate on a daily basis
and summer I realize I have so much
weird PTSD around summer and swimming
because our parents lied to us so much
liza minnelli I still I just choked on
my own hair I still when I go swimming
I'm like I just ate I can't swim for 30
minutes like I still have that that is
not a real thing as I grow I'm like oh
my god our parents just fucking told us
that so that they could get a break like
a friend of mine came over with her kids
and she was like no swimming for 30
minutes or else you're gonna choke and
like these kids are sitting there like
terrified to go in the pool after they
ate and she was just like okay now I can
finally pull my shit together and I was
oh my god our parents lied to us about
that shit so much as kids and I totally
thought it was what I thought if I going
Poole the food's gonna like move around
because of the water see I still believe
that see get in the pool and I'm like
I'm a lava lamp that's good parenting to
me because I think my parents wanted a
break so bad they were like get in the
pool maybe you're drowned like the other
thing they would say is oh if you eat
these seeds and then go in the wat like
we'd eat watermelon me like if then if
you're in the pool it's gonna grow a
tree in your stomach and I remember
being so traumatized by that my literal
dream was for that to happen to me I
used to eat the seeds to the point where
my mama took me to the doctor because I
used to eat seed and then pray a bit
please God let a tree grow inside me I
thought I would have plant powers so
like five to seven you want playing
powers you should just smoke some weed
we'll talk about that within it the
other thing that traumatized me is that
my my everyone would say if you pee in
the pool it's gonna turn purple like
that was a lie that was told that is a
myth that was told to kids so they
wouldn't pee in pools I wouldn't even go
swimming I was so afraid because I was
like what if there's like leftover pee
like from like Earl like or pee and my
silly I just wouldn't even go in the
pool because I was so terrified of being
humiliated by that and now as an adult
you'll look back and you're like oh like
there's no way anyone would put in a
public pool a chemical that would turn
urine purple that would that would be so
that also our eyeballs would burn off
they were saving it for your tie-dyed
shirts but like there it would be actual
battery acid like there was there's no
way that would be a thing and then I
remember my parents would always say
like if you do make a certain face that
your face will freeze that way yeah
think about it everyone got that but now
I look back and I'm like okay they would
lie to us about peeing in the pool they
would lie to us about you can't swim 30
minutes after and then we would make a
face like whatever and then they'd be
like and your face is gonna freeze that
way I'm like Jesus like all you guys did
was lie to us and then when we had a
same reaction you were like your face is
gonna freeze that way though those are
so nice from the ones I got my mom used
to tell me things like the sewer grates
in the road is where they put bad kids
yeah she would tell me I said good she
told me forever that I was allergic to
marijuana okay I mean some people really
are I don't feel great on it I start
texting exes and firing people tell me
if I drew
myself have a good ain't poisoning she
told me if I was bad that chucky the
killer doll would come after me yeah she
told me that a lot like a lot like too
much I mean I I got some really dark
ones my mom used to say that the ice
cream truck if it played music that
meant it was out of ice cream
that's cold my dad used to say that the
TV only worked when it rained like the
rain is what like mate org I like that
one and and oh and by the way your
childhood dog does not live on a farm
dad I wish the Miller told me that see
this is why I trust no bitch our parents
just lied to us over and over again in
the summer makes me like realize how
many things that are just not true but
yeah because they were lying constantly
do you know how many you know how long
did I ate all my steaks well done
because my mom told me that if I ate a
steak that wasn't well done I would get
mad cow disease okay
years I don't think I I'm with your mom
on this one you and my momma
huh truly gonna live um yeah mm-hmm I
would say you look really good okay that
smells great I know what is it is HASC
house dry shampoo so I would say that
all anybody's talking about in Hollywood
right now is my hair it's volume is it's
below luminous no I'm adding words
together I'm a creator okay so you're
gonna pull up the copy in case I get
stuff wrong because I don't need to read
copy as you know that's my brand's okay
I actually use the products that sponsor
our podcast and I actually believe in
them unlike some of these phonies and
fakers out there that y'all are
listening to that just lifelessly
read ads phone it in don't care no
passion nothing or frankly they mock the
advertiser not me
task actually using it but wait this
isn't the hairspray I need the hairspray
part I recently cut my hair and I was so
afraid because I was worried it was
gonna be all like flat and I was just
gonna look like a nasty wet rat
but I realized dry shampoo is what makes
it look cute let me smell great can you
tell us a little bit about this product
I can't but I want to start off by
saying that they have a biotin
puh what you know about and helps your
hair grow look at these roots I've been
using it look at these roots
yes Harris whirlwind this is biotin
boost okay so this is what I do because
I also realized if you wash your hair
too much it's just gonna get flatter and
it's also Jesus that was like a little
bit askew so what I do is I just do it
right in the roots and I'm not even
joking the lover that I have taken on
every time I use this he's like what is
that perfume like what is that smell
it's like of any perfume I've ever worn
it also is my favorite smell you're like
I've told you every time what it is stop
asking yes do you want to read some
stuff yeah I do you know that hat you're
part of Hollywood and you know that ask
is the number that's yes because anytime
on movie sets this is always what they
use number one private views on
television it's when it's high def use
it's almost like a microscope and if any
hairs are like too frizzy or out of line
you have to have the best best best
hairspray to hold and that's what this
does and it also when some of them
television they have to do like all day
it has to look the same and you know how
your hair normally just gets like oily
and greasy ER and like that doesn't hold
the curl throughout the day the reason
people use this is because it actually
holds the curl all day and keeps it from
being light and kind your hair it's
really clean it doesn't leave that
powder your residue okay no I'm not
being funny about this I'm just telling
the truth is going I need a break from
talking you go yeah well you have to
stop first
go ask offers are good for you formula
that won't break the bank including
shampoos conditioners deep conditioners
shine oils and dry shampoos that are
designed to treat and repair all types
of hair and made from clean ingredients
source from around the globe has is all
about second day hair and with the new
collection of half dry shampoos you're
covered no matter what your hair type is
hask offers for lightweight dry shampoos
with that have things such as biotin
coconut charcoal and chai all of which
provide charcoal all of which provide
long lasting absorption to leave your
hair fresh and clean even if you skip a
wash for just I mean like you're using
two at a time and you still we've had it
for months I've had both of these for
literally three months and they're still
full all house products are color safe
free of sulfates parabens dye a family
artificial colors and gluten when while
formulated to meet the needs of your
specific hair types they're also cruelty
free and because of their ingredients
inspired fragrances they smell
incredible as you know we love the
product so much we talked about it a lot
and right now we're excited to announce
that ask is now hosting weekly giveaways
for our listeners where you can win $100
prize pack that includes shampoos
conditioners leave-in sprays dry
shampoos and more for your chance to win
enter the giveaway at hasp UT comm slash
Whitney that's Haskett e-comm slash
Whitney and we thank you for sponsoring
this podcast making me a sex symbol
I'm telling you Haas beauty is why I am
officially an influencer now we did a
photo shoot yesterday and I looked very
cute and my hair just is irresistible
it's truly incredible I know like young
men want to date me I was 26 DME today
I'm just telling you you're the Farrah
Fawcett of our generation okay now let's
talk about ritual vitamins because you
guys know I you know my story with
ritual you know that I was taking ritual
before they even sponsored our podcast
called manifesting and look we had dr.
agus on the show last week we talked
about this he was very clear that a lot
of the ways that we get our omega oils
are dangerous for us you know
mercury is a really big problem in fish
oil and tuna exactly right so part of
the reason that ritual is so essential
for me that I don't have to worry about
like is this have mercury in it does
have chemicals in it like with how
polluted the oceans are so this is why I
love ritual and also because I'm not
gonna lie I've used other Omega
supplements and you feel like you're
burping up warf the rest of the day you
feel like you're just like like you know
burping up oysters in people's faces
it's it's even if you're wearing a mask
then you have to burp it up in your own
inhale your own sort of fish market
whereas this they have little mints yeah
it keeps your breath fresh the little
mint temps there also it's so much
easier than what I do which is where I
go down to the stream I catch a bunch of
salmon I eat them it's just so miss is
so much easier if you delivered right to
your door
ritual has all the nutrients most of us
don't get enough of from food there's no
shady additives or ingredients or weird
scams super easy to take capsules they
provide 9 nutrients you need to support
a strong foundation for your health also
this is a side note that's not in the
copy at all when you I carry them around
with me in my purse and when inevitably
the bottle opens and they all spread all
over your purse they don't explode which
is really helpful and your purse smells
delicious and minty and not like trout
ritual essential for women is a
multivitamin but reimagined it's got
from d3 to omega-3 rituals essential for
women helps fill gaps in a woman's diet
there no nausea capsule design is gentle
on an empty stomach and there's a mint
tab in every bottle to keep things fresh
so you don't get that fishy aftertaste
which we talked about um it's also
there's so much weird stuff in our food
now even in our vitamins you do not have
to worry about this there it's vegan
friendly it's sugar-free it's non-gmo
gluten-free allergen free you don't have
to worry about any shady weird red
number 5 benzo Mike's gas love plate you
pronounce everything that's in it which
is usually my rule if I'm going to put
something in my mouth or not that
sounded weird ritual also delivered to
you you don't have to keep up with it my
whole deal with vitamins is that once I
run out I'm just done I'm like alright
well I took that vitamin for three weeks
and now it's out so that's that and then
I'm like remember what I used to take
that vitamin they handle it for you
it's subscription so it comes to you by
the time you run out you already have a
new bottle so you do you're not left to
your own devices better health doesn't
happen overnight and ritual is now
offering our listeners 10% off during
your first three months fill in the gaps
in your diet with essential for women a
small step that helps support healthy
foundation for your body we're in a
pandemic people you have got to take
care of your immune system you have got
to take care of your health right now
more than
ever this is not a game ritual calm
slash Whitney start your ritual today
it's a no-brainer I do it what no I'm
just oh you look like you're about as
memorized by this you're so passionate
I'm I'm really like there's no excuse to
not take care of your health especially
right now with what is going on get this
for your sister get this for your mother
get this for like this is what you
should be gifting your family someone
asks you for a mint just give them one
of these give this to your wife give
this to the people you care about like
there is no reason that we should not be
taking care of ourselves right now look
at what is going on in the news control
what you can control there's a lot that
we cannot control right now your immune
system you can control dr. agus was just
on you need to sleep and you need to be
taking omegas you need to be taking
vitamin D I mean it there's no excuse my
producers are laughing and we got a code
for them yeah a code yes ritual calm /
Whitney 10% off during your first three
months do it you're gonna save money in
the long run I'm telling you you heard
it here on one can't tell you I'm on one
people are testing me people are testing
me this month it's too much I'm very
emotional and as you guys know I work in
a business that is full of fucking
goblins and I've had it I've done
it's a while to me full of goblin we're
in the labyrinth I I guess I'm just like
thinking a lot about like what's going
on you know as you guys know in the last
couple weeks like a lot of you know
there's been a magnifying glass on
certainly magnifying glass or is
magnifying glass glass no a telescope
there have been binoculars on the comedy
community I don't even know what you
call it been a monocle physicist no but
it seems like there's like a second wave
of me - is what I mute a second yeah so
me - round to me - squared huh me
squared and I guess I just think about
this and you know you know I've always
had a thorn in my side about this
business in terms of like the movie
that have always been made and I was
thinking about it and like like people
can you believe this and I'm like yes I
can believe this the this business
started this business was built on the
back of a child named Shirley Temple
okay
the cornerstone of Hollywood was a
five-year-old that would tap dance in a
miniskirt
yes I can believe this is a creepy
business five year old a two-inch
hemline like what is going on like I
think about Shirley temple's so much
like when this shit happens like the
first movies to turn Hollywood it was an
actionable toddler I mean I was going
back because no one listens to me when I
say this stuff I was going back and like
watching Shirley tumbled movies because
I'm like oh I overthink things and I'm a
comedian and it's our job to like poke
holes and things and like Donna I have
you seen the good ship lollipop video
yeah yeah it's truant it's truly
traumatizing did you watch it now this
is a Shirley Temple
every movie she was in it's her and like
40 men the story lines always end up
being her in like 40 minutes always like
her with like the whole Navy or her like
on a plane with 50 guys is like none of
which are her dad none of them are ever
heard she's always like an orphan and
then all the men are like competing to
adopt her I don't fucking know but she's
always with like got a ton of men in a
miniskirt like some kind of like uniform
and then she's like serenading them and
like flirting with them and I rewatched
this like with fresh eyes dude this this
shit does not hold up she's on a ship
singing to like eight men not a woman in
sight not even like a flight attendant
no chaperone just only dudes she's there
nobody knows how I don't know where
they're going and she's just like the
good shit blood like she's like moving
her shoulders and like wagging her
finger at these men now you know there's
no women around because of her hair it's
truly one of those they were like I
don't know rub some dirt in it like it's
truly a crazy
like her she's it a micro mini first
she's in these shortest dress I've ever
seen she's like she's a child Twiggy
it's crazy and they took that every time
she dances like her like panties peek
out of these are like bloomers they're
like diapers diapers you're seeing them
like peek out I'm just like very
disturbed what is going on and I it's
just like where's the mom I and then at
the end of this good ship lollipop I'm
like watching it in horror I watched it
with a friend of mine for your fingers
oh yeah just to make sure that I wasn't
completely off-base here and we were all
gasping watching it first of all at the
end of the song as if it's not weird
enough that they're like passing her
around holding her by her sternum like
moving she at the end they put a cake in
her face and they like and then multiple
times it off and there's like white
icing on her face I'm like I know I did
a special called money shot I'm probably
looking for something that isn't there
is that is creepy to everyone else that
is it is to me what is now it's
definitely for people no you know what
we're in Shirley Temple for me is her
very first movie is called war babies
and she plays an exotic dancer for other
child soldiers know this I did a deep
dive into this this weekend there was a
whole series called burlesque babies are
two things that and it was babies that
were like five
reenacting adult movies but as babies so
she was playing like a saloon whore that
was what it was wearing like an
off-the-shoulder like pillow like
peasant top she was literally off the
shoulder like someone was like there was
someone that like pulled it off the
shoulder no child things to put thanks
to pull and she's kissing the other boy
babies in exchange for a candy way
they're just recreating the best little
whorehouse in Texas so insane dude I'm
like watching this and just like so
shocked because there was also I've made
movies I've made movies and I know how
movies are made so I can't separate what
I'm look
well first I was just like kids playing
I'm like no no I know how many times the
older men told her you now have to kiss
the other boy and then he gives you
candy like that conversation haunts me
like there was one I was watching where
she's um truly at war she's all hands no
she's on an actual battlefield
III don't know she's always like in the
military and all these movies she's in a
military uniform that's like a little
miniskirt yeah what else has she been
like a little hat and she's like on a
battlefield like I'm not even joking
like in the trenches or barracks with
other soldiers with guns like I don't
know why a child is there anyway and she
like is with a man who's of course on
her father and she like rolls under a
fence or something and gets up and he
starts wiping off her butt where the
dust is like cleaning her off and I just
was like okay this is a girl who is
famously agile she's famously good at
tap dancing she can a sleeve she's she
could write wiper own skirt off sir like
like and then I thought about I was like
for those of you that don't know how
movies are made like you have to repeat
a scene like 40 times they did that 40
times and the director was like yes sir
whatever the fuck his name was Jerry I
don't know wipe her butt off and they
did it 14 but do it again 40 different
angles 40 different times like he was
just spanking her but for like a full
day and I'm irate but you know she
doesn't have some bangers though dude
animal crackers in my zoo dude good ship
lollipop is a bop good ship lollipop
oh yeah the good shit lollipop and a
stroke you know I'm saying good ship
lollipop is a jam and I mean look she
was very talented I mean when you go
back and watch your dancing you're like
she'll tap you under a house great I
just don't I I I don't like we were
talking about the bed and I were talking
monthís yesterday like just how like
sexualized everything is in this
business like I got cast in an animated
movie that never got made but I was an
airplane
and I show up and they show me like the
sketch of it or whatever and it was like
a sexy airplane like lipstick on and
lashes and I was like why doesn't why do
i why did why are you trying to make
people on a fucking airplane that's why
airplane have to be sexy it's an
airplane like it's already in the shape
of a dick first of all there's it's
already inherently phallic also it's
just like an airplane is a tube of farts
this is never gonna be sexual why why
don't you make what are we doing like
why does everything have to be so sexual
and also so many things have been
successful that weren't hyper sexualized
like remember the fucking Snapple lady
dude oh she with grain dude Snapple the
Snapple lady was what about a late a
lady that was like have some Snapple
that campaign was huge member yeah I was
sitting there in my hyper color cancer
shirt saying yes I would like to buy us
now one of my favorite commercials
growing up was and that's the power of
pine saw a baby the pine yeah like you
can hire adult women to sell your
product but there is this weird thing
where we head where we need like
children's do it like jewelry the old
copper tone logo oh god yeah it was just
a child with getting hurt with her butt
out like no it was a dog oh yeah like
repelling her on underwear off that's
horribly weird and creepy in itself but
also she was the spokesperson for the
brand was tan without burning why is a
toddler tanning in the Sun like well who
was buying that for their child like oh
and also I resent that because the dog
was pulling her underwear off dogs are
not the perverts here okay and you can
you can those insulting to dogs you can
use I can't remember that and she had
like pigtail bottoms it yeah and there
was no reason for that because you could
use to look the Morton Salt girl she's
humble she's a nice young lady I dressed
his Morton Salt girl for Halloween she
has no distinctive features she's just
trying to stay out of the rain and her
skirt is an appropriate length yeah she
has I think she has a rain boots on you
know who else
the great child star face of a Wendy's
girl Wendy's girl she's wearing a high
collar she has age-appropriate hair yep
she's the heiress to a fortune love it
yes there's ways to have children and
things that aren't kooky but also hire
an adult there's also that you could
just see that - I also the Wendy's girls
are drawing was help yeah she is a
drawing but she's a good one I do
that's right now that I'm thinking about
it it was like her her dress went up to
her neck she was a pilgrim giving out a
burger she was like y'all like pasty
nuggets there so they were like
literally it goes up to her chest it's
just that she's wearing it over he's
wearing full mast was just freckles in
pictures not sexualized
at all I appreciate that like you know
like America loves to sexualize things
but not talk about sex that's like it's
like their favorite thing to do which I
feel like if we if we talked more about
sex things will be less sexualized well
which is why we have an only fan but I
also like there's so much stuff like
like that doesn't hold up for me when
you look back with like fresh eyes like
I look I know was 'red of Oz as a
masterpiece I know it is the most
watched movie of all time
yeah always rub me the wrong way that's
not a masturbation reference it always
it always rubbed me the wrong way
because you know what it was it was like
I remember even as a kid going like why
do those guys have to be so old like why
is this Jill I mean I remember being
like that lion looks like an old lion
like why is this girl hanging out with
all these old guys like I remember just
being like like why can't the lion be
like a young lion like why does it like
or like why does a scarecrow like even
for a scarecrow that motherfucker was
old like it was he was such an old
scarecrow and to me I was like why is
this young girl hanging out with all
these old men and like taking care of
their feeling just like like like it was
kinda like Barney dude Barney the
Dinosaur always seemed like a young
dinosaur you didn't seem like an old
dinosaur even though dinosaurs are
extinct he's still the same job
surely he felt like young in Shirou baqr
right though they felt very old I went
back and watched after you brought this
up and I was like it's literally like
she landed in like she landed in this
magical world like work at a hospice
they're like like can you take care of
these man now but go I like what's going
back through and I was like all she's
doing is emotionally caring for these
grown men this young teenage girl is
like she started like walking down the
street in like old men are just like
joining her on her walk which is every
girl's fucking nightmare she also
rescuing them first she's she's
completely taking care of the feelings
and solving problems of older men that
should be able to solve their own
problems so like the Cowardly Lion is a
crying and he's scared of some shit or
whatever and she's like wiping his tears
and it's like you're gonna be okay I'm
like that's why are you solving this
grown man's problem and then tin man is
all rusty or whatever and she's got like
oil him up I'm like why is this teenager
lubing up this man's parts why can't the
fucking Scarecrow Lubin mottling why is
she having to solve all these men's
problems like the scarecrows like stuck
and she has to get him down and like
just the training of like as a girl you
have to take care of every grown man
when it's actually their job to fucking
right problem you know how fast she
woulda got to Oz or shoot him under
Holland damn business she could have
skipped down that yellow brick road and
those in those fabulous red bottoms have
been right there couldn't she they were
holding her back even the munchkins were
like 60 they're taking fucking naps and
poppies like sob like it was the whole
movie was here's a young girl who has to
have everything figured out and be super
adult and then take care of the emotions
of all these men that is like the whole
movie and then uh and it's just like
creepy I just wanna be they look so old
and then oh my god everyone's like well
if you play the movie backwards to Pink
Floyd it matches up
it's a Pink Floyd song like artal if you
play it forward it's a R Kelly song
first of all let's just be you play
afford it's a snuff film it's just like
I guess I just feel like like it was
just like so weird me and then the only
women in the movie are witches of course
they're like witches
like there's no like cool women they're
like yeah I'll come with you and help
you and won't like she's any friends
she's also 16 in the movie she's six
when we watched it I thought she was
like 30 or something you know and then
you grow up and you realize like oh like
I looked her I looked her up in real
life Judy Garland was 16 working with
all these guys and the load my gut was
right because I found out that the
director when she got the job told her
to lose 12 pounds which is such a
specific amount of weight that is such a
weird like how closely they must have
examined her body to come up with the
number 12
not like 10 15 like 12 we've measured
your body and scrutinized it and 12
pounds and then this is a true fact
google it
while filming the scene when Dorothy
slaps the lion Judy Garland couldn't
stop giggling so the director of Victor
Fleming took her aside and slapped her
after which she nailed the scene in one
take first of all love true facts first
of all what is this guy alive put me in
a cage with Victor Fleming this
motherfucker what are like what is he
dead yeah can we go pee on his boat can
we go pee on his grave I hate this
person that is a crazy thing to do but
you did Benton made a good point
yesterday because Benton loves he knows
I'm trouser right now so he's not
disagreeing with me a lot he loves
Wizard of Oz I love it but for just I
mean I watched it so much that my mom
broke it and tell me that that's that
she lost the movie so also by the way it
you did say those were her uncle's
Oh in the movie yeah those people member
she wakes up and she's like you were
there and you were there yeah everyone's
there but you made the really good point
about how all the women like nobody
helped her like there's there's just
fully magical wish that comes down in a
bubble and she's like can you think this
out on your own because there's no girl
power or not even if they're her uncle's
they should be able to solve their own
problems even more the reason I'd like
the three creepy uncles chasing around
in costumes like it's all weird also her
aunt is the Wicked Witch correct when
she wakes up her aunt is like her total
the villain oh I don't know also there's
a lot of interesting stuff about in the
making of the movie
of the make up play work the Renaissance
yeah a lot of the make up like burned
our skin like a lot of the crazy
shipment yeah The Tin Man got clown mom
Benton was texting me about clown long
at 2:00 in the morning clown lung is our
thing I learned this week what's clown
like it's a slang term coined by like a
performer that clowns or like drag
queens it's whenever you breathe in so
much powder with talc in it yeah that it
gives you emphysema or like causes
cancer in the lungs or something like
that talk free yeah as I'm putting on
powder to carpet yeah you're not
supposed to breathe in powders and when
you breathe in so much it just it sits
in your lungs so you can't you know I
can't go anywhere I got in the tinman he
got it really bad act don't know the
actor that played the Tin Man the first
guy had to quit because his lungs
collapsed
yeah because because they were breathe
the the silver paint it was it's it's
aluminum yeah it's a little just
breathing in metal over and over and
over that's very interesting hot fact
Hollywood's a fucking nightmare that's
what that's what we're trying to say
it's a nightmare beginning to fucking at
it's always been a nightmare it's a
cesspool gusting swamp but you were
really into rewatching The Wizard of Oz
which made me think about what movies
can i rewatch what movies do i feel
differently about now go back which ones
hold up yeah and I rewatched the 2002
classic film crossroads Starring Britney
Spears written by the legendary Shonda
Rimes and it is an adult movie there are
a lot of movies that we watched as kids
when you go back and you watch them now
you're like like Dirty Dancing there's
an abortion and Dirty Dancing the whole
movie is about an abortion crossroads
the girl is literally sexually assaulted
gets pregnant loses the baby Britney
Spears mom does not want her when she
goes back and finds her the other girls
mom fat shames her sent her to a camp
they're all doing this to take place in
the comedy community probably and like
it is the true Shonda Rhimes film okay
all i got out of it when I was little
all I saw in that movie was a rock and I
was I fully just followed Britney Spears
me baby go back as an adult and now I'm
like yeah wow like how every Disney
movie it's like someone's dad died like
everything is just so tragic we just
like didn't see him when we were kids
you know but that just gets filed away
all right we have to keep moving
we I'm gonna try to get this podcast
back to of like a consistent place it's
been a wild time in the world you guys
know that I always want to get people on
that who would be the person that I
would want to listen here in the moment
of what's going on I do though there's a
lot of recurring segments that you guys
really like like fears resentments my
producer just had a stroke are you okay
you're gonna make it
what was that is that co vid do we all
have Co vid knows mine alone I don't
know my producer has clown long you guys
he literally just like puked out of his
nose he's also drinking Mountain Dew
your body is probably just internally
exploding Mountain Dew you guys my
producer is drinking Mountain Dew and
his nose is just bleeding he's bleeding
from the eyes he's bleeding from the
mouth he's just spontaneously combusted
but not because amount do please don't
see us would you like a water
Jesus relatable content because I was
like there's a lot of segments you guys
really like and if he was just yeah I
thought you laughed at first I thought
you meant about your exam you probably
saw me on camera when you guys are
loving the podcast is a bitch these
numbers you're lucky we got this sponsor
keep going
you have the copy ready please because I
don't read copy because I'm authentic
and I speak from the heart you guys know
this about me I wore this is swear to
God truce true fact I wore my undies
yesterday on a bike ride bike riding is
my new thing I go mountain biking and I
cry while listening to Eminem that's the
way I'm going through the world right
now that's just how it's going there's
proof of this you guys have seen it I am
there's also an AWOL nation song that I
listen to as I'm going up a hill and I
pretend that I'm like if I can get there
fast enough I'm gonna save a bunch of
elephants this is my process
the point is bike seats are a nightmare
bikes are sexist and misogynist much
like toilets and the only reason I am
able to freaking bike is cuz me undies
don't give me more like a front wedgie
because bikes give you a front wedgie
and me undies underwear I swear to God
yesterday was the first time that I
wasn't like pulling underwear out of all
my crevices cuz me undies stays where
you put it I guess I can stop cutting in
front of my underwear out then no then I
know that no there's something about me
undies I don't even know the copy but we
know the outside of me undies like is
tight in a way that doesn't rub and give
you like a nasty rash that you then have
to explain to your lover later like it's
my underwear I swear and it's like super
soft but also stays in place like you
know they're the most comfortable
underwear they just are I don't like I
don't like I was about to say why do
they even need to advertise because we
need a podcast um but the way that I do
it I mean you I don't can you take read
the ad to me because I don't even yeah
you know the why hold on the technology
of these underwear I swear I'm swear to
god I'm speaking from the heart
I tell no lies here if I didn't think
that this was right I would have made a
statement by now trust me the it's a
thong that goes up but you know when you
put spandex over a thong it the thong
keeps moving around you can put spandex
on and sweat and get all you know damp
and moist and it doesn't start to wither
away and give you a front wedgie I just
have a question were you reading from an
ad just then or no this is just I just
wanna be sure my heart cuz that's what I
do well you know that's you know what
the worst thing possible ever is I read
that sentence completely backwards yeah
do you know what the worst possible
thing ever is an empty underwear drawer
because it's all in the dirty laundry
well good thing you can just get me an D
membership mine was it it was but you're
making me read this listen here's the
point me Andes has a has a great offer
for the listeners free oh my god they
really are soft this so soft they do
have really cute prints remember the one
you got me with the llamas on it I know
they won they there's one with unicorns
on over now why don't you get me them I
did also ask you to order them for me
okay
listen to me I'll do that mom me undies
has a great offer for listeners right
now for the first time purchasers you
get 50% off and free shipping this is a
no-brainer especially because they have
a hundred percent satisfaction guarantee
I'm 100 percent satisfied ticket row is
my tush agree to get your 50% off your
first order free shipping and a
hundred-percent satisfaction guaranteed
go to meet undies dot-com / Whitney you
know like me and ease comm / Whitney yes
what do you like I also like they come
subscription so I don't know life is a
nightmare right now but there's when you
get it like subscription underwear and
you just are like it's almost like Santa
Claus or something it's like Christmas
morning when you just like get a
delivery and you're like a new paradigm
yeah I mean I'm not even lying I have
two subscriptions because I want two
different styles so I pay for two and
they send me to every pair every month
there's just something nice about like
being surprised with like a pair of
underwear like that you weren't
necessarily expecting it's just like how
like a little treat for yourself I have
and wonder where in years I just wear
the parasol my way okay so me undies are
available in a range of sizes extra
small to four X L by the way I also I
might let us say this I can put them in
the dryer and they don't get all screwed
up no they're I mean they're the perfect
underwear underwear you can't even put
them the dryer because they start to
fall apart this is not a copy I'm just
telling you guys you can put in the
dryer Mia undies has a great offer for
my listeners first-time purchasers
you're gonna get 15% off and free
shipping get 15% off your first pair
free shipping and 100% satisfaction
guarantee ah go to me undies dot-com
slash Whitney that's my name the undies
dot-com slash Whitney and send us
pictures I mean oh god send like a door
- well door - Benton okay I have been
using tor - you have we loved order you
know what in a way that is like it's
really about it's just like a regular
this is just a daily thing at this point
not only because of kovat but the last
couple weeks have been rough and there
is nothing more soothing just having
someone bring food to you like feels
like you have a friend like you're
bringing you like
it's just like oh I thought you might
need this chicken in a soup I did it
really is like having someone bring you
food like I think these last couple
weeks that have been just very hard like
having to cook yourself food having to
go to the grocery store having that
whole rigmarole just having someone
bring you food and I've been getting so
into it Benton came in the other day
this is a little trigger I came in I
came in and you and your lover had
ordered Ruth's Chris but don't get me
wrong I like Ruth's Chris but I was like
did you come back from prom what were
you two doing like why are you like are
you like am i arguing the moms going out
tonight
like what is going Ruth Chris and you
were like yeah yeah I in order with
Chris and I was like for who it's called
self care is what it is I wanted some
creamed spinach an entire pie from door
- the other day and then I called my
friends in FaceTime and had them watch
me eat it while I reviewed it okay so I
feel like I'm using mine more
appropriately than you it was like yeah
that's gonna mess up your algorithm
deeply mmm that feels like a fad my
person I'm not gonna cosign on but I
think it's just like I I've been trying
to cook I can't like and also what I'd
like to do is I like to I order on door
- more than I need and then I eat it the
next day that's my other thing Whitney
loves nothing more than called food
Whitney is upsets her fetish she is
obsessed with if she can even hang out
the freezer she would do it I will cook
food I've ordered or - fries I will have
it all set up nicely hi she will go out
of her way to find something to do so
that food gets cold I'm like I'm just
gonna go home I came in I don't wanna
look it drives me I hate people eating
cold food door - will deliver you hot
fresh food I know but then I like to get
more than I need save it for the next
day it's a psychopath you're a psycho
and I did I've been getting that Thai
food that Pad Thai we ordered that the
other day
I know door - I mean it's so convenient
things called that we got the cream
cheese crab wontons Whitney looked at me
dead in the face that you ever had a
crab wonton I was like yes I've been to
every Asian restaurant in a mirror what
do you could not believe crab wontons
exist I believe I just discovered it was
the funniest oh we love door - it makes
great for a moment three
three thousand partners in the US Puerto
Rico Canada and Australia and I didn't
Porto Rico Canada Australia you can
support your local NGO twos which is
very very important to restaurants right
now need your business
or you can order from your favorite
national restaurants like Chipotle where
every guy took me on dates in my 20s and
I thought it was fancy Wendy's and the
Cheesecake Factory the Cheesecake from
there for a cheesecake never been a
bigger menu many of our favorite of your
favorite lo ours we are one someone's
favorite local restaurants are open for
deliveries to just open go to door - app
look it's on my phone you keep reading
an offshore everyone select your
favorite local restaurant and your food
will be left at your door I have it
right here and I like their little there
what do you call that app thing it's
really easy it's white with the little
red thing it's on my homepage huh icon
thank you thank you I am an icon I agree
icon legend star
Jordache delivery this is very important
on my home page if you've made my if
you're an app that has made my homepage
that's a really big deal look at that
BAM right there right the closest one to
my thumb door - this is really important
door - deliver deliveries our contact
lists right now our listeners can get
five dollars off and zero delivery fees
on their first order of $15 or more when
you download the door - happen into the
code good that's five dollars off and
zero delivery fees on your first order
when you download the door - app and the
app store it into the code good for you
don't forget that code is good for you
for five dollars off your first order
with door - good for you
it was out is that right okay that's it
okay all right so that's the first time
we've done ads within the show I hope it
wasn't jarring a lot of people were
saying that like in the last couple
weeks of interviews it was like we're
talking right really serious stuff and
then I'm like never sleep my hair like
tonally the shifts are very intense so
we might start trying to do the ads
really wait speaking of no been talking
for tonally weird shifts okay we talked
about you and the doctor but doctor
and the questions you were trying first
I sorry I thought you met the doctor I
was dating my doctor lover I I would
like to first say I that was the first
doctor we've had on the show we were
gonna have more dr. agus welcome back I
think people loved him he was so
soothing he it was just so nice to talk
to someone that knew what they were
talking about and wasn't like dramatic
or histrionic or misleading I literally
was listening to him I was like it's
this what it's like to have a father
like I feel she was great I feel so like
like like I feel like everything's gonna
work be okay that's what he made her he
was a great I mean a great day also just
was like you know when we watch the news
you have to understand the people that
go on the news it's their job to catch
your attention it's their actors at this
point that's their job to try to get you
to keep watching and to be dramatically
he was just so calm and I really
appreciated that doctors are great guess
we should have helped well have more by
dr. Meredith Grey what I don't know that
is Oh from okay you know what you know
what I don't need I don't need to be
mocked right now no if we're gonna have
it it's gonna be McSteamy is that what
the name is yeah but yeah yeah what he
died on the show and I remember I was
gonna ask all the questions like the
dumb questions that's what I try to do
for you guys on this podcast and I asked
him I was like so do cell phones cause
cancer and I realize as soon as I ask
that question like if the answer had
been yes like what was I gonna do like
if if we thank God the answer was no it
was so funny to watch because well first
of all if he said yes cell phones gots
cancer I'd be like well okay my behavior
would not have changed at all like
there's nothing I could have I would've
been like alright well I guess I'm just
gonna die at 60 also fully asking a
question we solved years ago you're like
hey can we show use our cell phones by
the gas pumper no just a quick question
doctor if I step on a crack when I break
my mother's back or or what a science
say can I swallow this gum or no he's
like do you want to talk about what's
going on in the world you drink while
you're pregnant
yes or not like do carrots give me night
vision
why do rabbits have such good eyesight I
want the answers doctor
he's like mm-hmm he's asked if you can
swim after you you can at your lava lamp
it was also could you tell it was so
hard for me to not make jokes yeah a
little yes he's like so um anyways
there's some rough things going on in
the world I want you had the information
you were like you were like our ball
pits really a germ festival it was like
you don't know your blood type and I
want to bag it it was like the craziest
well there's so many things that I feel
like or unfortunately science is under
attack there are a lot of as I move
through the world I really science
there's still a lot of things people are
still on the fence about notice back to
eighth grade so you were fully just
packing like eighth grade science I
described all the types of clouds like
do we need to drink water every day
you're like the mitochondria is the
powerhouse of the snail I feel like
we've been lied to so much as children
that now I still feel like there's a lot
of like old lies I still have kicking
around in my head it was so funny but I
want to have more doctors on the show I
want to have more like scientists on the
show we're gonna do that and I'm very
excited people send in a lot of very
good questions I wanted to ask him more
about but it was like two hours long I
have to get back to like making the
vaccine I can't stay here any longer so
I couldn't keep him that much longer
doing asking about let us know I know so
send in more questions send in more
ideas for guests that you want to see
coming up merch is available Benson I
know merch is available listen we have
merch it is here and it is queer this
month yeah and you should get it it's
for it's great it's going to charity so
a portion of the sale it's for merch we
are I promise gonna do a bad yes we're
working on another merge it does were
one thing at a time but we're doing
onesies a little chaotic
are you just saying things and that
we're
let me write that down I guess we're
gonna make those big coyote one um also
please make sure you're sending us
voicemails we won't get Mike to doing
those voicemails we're gonna be doing
listening to more of your voicemails and
text me eight one eight two three nine
seven five two seven little refresher
course this is so you can text me
directly I sent our birthday messages
everyday I sent it exclusive podcast
clips this is how you guys can send me
ideas for the podcast I do read them I
can't respond to all of your messages
I'm also not Google I love that you guys
are like hey my dog has he need a couple
hours what should I do I'm like what I'm
right that she's not a doctor I'm not a
doctor as you may have noticed like
there are certain things I can't I mean
people will text me be like hey there's
a stray dog on the side of the road and
Pensacola where are you i'm like i live
in caliph
come get the straight also if Whitney
doesn't respond to you please don't text
me to ask her to respond please don't do
that
I respond as much as I can I send
birthday videos out every morning but
it's really important for tore up dates
podcast updates sometimes I get very
lonely and I respond to a lot of them
and then it's funny because the more I
responded people the more you guys think
it's Benton are automated which is
always so insulting I'll be texting with
like someone that has text amount like
back and forth and like who is this
really yeah I'd everything spelled
correctly it's not me that's just a fact
if you can read it it's not me so it's
important way that I can stay in touch
with you guys but you can texture it
especially given I really hope these
tour dates are gonna happen but with
everything that's going on and how much
things are rescheduling it's important
that I'm able to connect with you guys
directly because I can text you by city
whereas on Instagram I can't do that and
I don't want to blast out to my entire
feed dates that are just you know Tulsa
right so you can text her 8 1 8 2 3 9 7
5 to 7 and you can leave Google
voicemails at 8 1 8 5 3 8 9 9 4 0 you
can also buy the merch store that
Whitney Cummings calm please buy the
merch we worked very hard on it
tours like subscribe share here's the
other thing Benton is very upset like
about my YouTube like he wants me to
like do all this to do more
so I shall do you guys subscribe let's
say this if you guys subscribe more by
the way I'm really used the manscaped
nose trimmer I you did I not really yes
she uses it and then also announces that
she's using it should be in a different
room going I'm trimming my nose I
started trimming my nose hair with the
manscape thing they don't sponsor this
episode and I'm still this is how much I
believe in the product um but what she
was saying was that if you want to see
more content on YouTube and things like
that please subscribe subscribe I need
to be convinced yes the two hundred
thousand people subscribe now we're not
convincing enough yeah we need more
convinced I'm not convinced by you
people I need you to want me badly
[Music]
okay break Darwin elephants bye bye
[Applause]